when the alarm clock goes off monday
morning and kids rise and shine to head
back to school they want to be dressed
in something new and fresh and trendy i
checked out macy's at fashion show las
vegas where kids can own their style for
the school
year colleen lillard store manager is
with us to tell us what's hot and the
trends for back to school good morning
colleen good morning you've got some
great fashions here
what are kids wanting to wear back to
the classroom well let me tell you about
this so first of all as you can see
denim is hot hot hot hotter than it's
ever been and yes guys the 80s are back
so if any of you remember wearing these
cute little overalls overalls are it
you've got lots of denim layer up to
happen you've got tie-dye over here it's
so cute and the girls love this i see
flannel now this will come when it's
come in play when it's cooler right not
right now i have to tell you the girls
still wear flannel no matter what the
temperature is they're still going to
wear flannel because remember it still
gets a little chillier at night time but
the layered look is really really
popular so you put a little cute little
graphic tee your flannel layer it up
with your denim and you're good to go
okay 80s style denim flannel we got it
yeah what else is going on let me show
you the ones too let me show you what we
do look fashionable they do so really
really important is you're all inclusive
activewear guys so activewear is also
still very very hot super cute to wear
but let's talk about this this is a
brand that seems to have had a
resurgence champion yes so champion
really years ago champion you did a lot
of basics right now they're great with
fashion they really
just i would say reinvented the brand
you've got a lot of great fashion here a
lot of great value comes in this brand
and super cute for the kids and it's
just adorable look at the colors i know
how about the girl would not like these
colors and most everything usually comes
with that third layering piece for mom
to have put on okay when you're in the
cold air conditioning when you're in the
cold air conditioning if you're lucky
that your school has air conditioning
all right what else what for the little
ones the younger ones so we've got these
cute little um uh tommy hilfiger outfits
here for the cute little ones as well
and then you've got this look at this
who doesn't need this cute for picture
day because picture day usually comes up
towards the end of the month got a cute
little ralph lauren outfit for her as
well these are affordable designers
these are affordable designers these
have great value you know any time that
they're on sale usually 30 to 50 percent
off we can get you in a tommy hilfiger
or a polo at any given time and what
about the older kids back here let's get
some other talk about this what is this
i love it so this is artwork so a lot of
artwork is really popular right now that
we're embedding into either denim or
sweatshirts or so on and so forth like
that and then when you take a look at
this too so it's artwork and patchwork
which are the latest trends
yeah so you can see that the embroidery
look how cute that embroidery is that's
adorable so again like if you think
about the 70s inspiration the 80s
inspiration what's old is new right
where's the grunge is the grunge gone so
no it's called what modern day grunge i
don't i don't think grunge will ever be
gone you still got the ripped denim you
still got all of that stuff going on the
extra layers and all of that kind of
stuff for the older kids
but it's still very popular okay grunge
and you say graphic tees yeah you know i
think it's just about owning your style
and who you are and these are great
add-ons too so if you got a very busy
mom and they don't really know what the
kids are going to wear you know what
grab a bunch of tees one for every day
of the week
and you've got a cute little outfit you
layer it up with your your denim your
denim skirts your squirts whatever you
need and you're good to go and you look
super fashionable they are really cute
and super affordable so check it out
colleen says most of the styles that we
saw there at fashion show las vegas can
also be found at the neighborhood macy's
stores henderson summer and such and
they are always having sales including
this weekend
well we shopped for the newest back to
school fashions with colleen learned
store manager for macy's fashion show
las vegas and found out that the 80s are
coming back now let's check out the cool
accessories to complete your kids look
when they head back to the classroom
it's back to school we've covered the
clothing trends for kiddos now it's
about the accessories what they carry
what they wear on their feet just as
important as what they wear very much
very much so tell us about what's
trending for this year yeah so obviously
number one trend
white sneakers everything like you and i
used to i know just like you and i used
to wear but obviously nike or any other
brand super super number one trend for
the new school year backpacks you've got
to have a cool backpack gotta have a
backpack it's all about the backpack
what carries it i think anything that's
really inspired with unicorns or
avengers or for the fashionista
look how cute and soft that's adorable
for the younger ones uh the older girls
they seem to really like the purse kind
of backwards yeah i'm telling you i'm
telling you yep my daughter has one i
think in almost every vendor but that's
for the cute fashionista as you're
entering in middle school maybe high
school or even if you're off to college
right of course all right well i'd love
it but then you've even got some
matching ones too where you can have the
lunch box with the matching backpack
so you're really cool
for the kids who are carrying a lunch
kit they still like the superheroes the
the all the characters yep all the
characters i think unicorns still remain
number one for the young girls as you
can see here we've got the little input
for the water bottle super important to
carry your water bottle kids like
reusable water bottles very important to
be reusable yep very much so all right
got some action figures and then
obviously dinosaurs something for the
older kids teenagers makeup skin care
hair products you can't forget about
that no you can't and honestly it's one
of the most important things that you
can have how you take care of your kids
when or your skin when you're younger is
how it's going to transition when you're
older so super important to have all of
that great skin care for you now and
it's not only for like the acnes and
that kind of blemishes and stuff but
body odor i mean i'm sorry to say it
guys but it's gonna happen right yeah it
is and moisturizer is really important
again we live in that desert climate
being able to moisturize your skin
really really important very important
and hair care girls are very concerned
but guys are too yeah so important to
have the right hair care especially
that's not drying for your skin but
super cute little kit here as you're
getting ready for picture day
towards the end of the month really
important to take care of your hair as
well everything you need for having a
great back to school absolutely thank
you colleen you're welcome good stuff
all right kids there's so much there's
so much to keep up with well colleen
says that most of uh again most of the
styles that we looked at at fashion show
las vegas there could also be found in
the neighborhood stores so henderson
summerlin all the other macy's there so
uh and they're always having good sales
i don't know about you guys but i'm
always looking at the sales and macy's
sales and sales everywhere right now so
parents i'm sure you're probably already
doing a lot of that
shopping i have a question okay um
backpacks now both shoulders or because
you know it was just the one shoulder
when i was in school do you do you use
both well we were talking about the
backpack safety right for kids yeah for
their spine it's it's over
so that makes sense but is that what
they're doing well i don't know and even
a belt do you say even a little well
they're saying even if you can strap it
around the hips okay and and the
backpack should only be hold 20 percent
no more than 20 percent of a kid's
weight so in other words you can't like
oh but everything's online now so kids
really carrying the heavy-duty i don't
think so we look like turtles you know
yeah right looking this way it's a
chromebook yeah exactly it's a laptop or
an ipad or whatever the kids are using
so i'm sure there are a few books still
left out there
but